the University of Minnesota medical
school is prestigious has a great
reputation each year is ranked among the
best medical schools in the entire
country a man named Dr Robert Englander
is the associate Dean for undergraduate
medical education at the school and he
is like the institution he serves highly
regarded highly respected his resume
includes Yale Medical School Johns
Hopkins Harvard Medical School a
residency a children's National Medical
Center he's around the ivy league of
medical school gamut
and there was a time when all of that
stuff might have meant that the
University of Minnesota medical school
and men like Dr Robert Englund can be
trusted
but those days are long gone here's the
report from the Tennessee star quote
University of Minnesota medical school
students took an oath to quote promote a
culture of anti-racism during an August
19th white code ceremony white coats the
students said
um are themselves a symbol of power
Prestige and dominance therefore
students will quote strive to reclaim
their identity as a symbol of
responsibility humility and loving
kindness quote we commit to uprooting
the Legacy and perpetuation of
structural violence deeply embedded
within the Healthcare System students
said according to a video of the
ceremony Dr Robert Englander associate
Dean for undergraduate medical education
LED students in reciting oath which he
described as beautiful he said the class
oath was written by the students in
consultation with their faculty advisors
now you can't fully appreciate this
until you've actually seen the video
which was posted to Twitter by Chris
rufo and let's go through it now here it
is
with gratitude we the students of the
University of Minnesota Twin Cities
Medical School class of 2026. stand here
today among our friends families peers
mentors and communities who have
supported us in reaching this milestone
our institution is located on Dakota
land today many indigenous people
throughout the state including Dakota
and Ojibwe called the Twin Cities home
we also recognize this acknowledgment is
not enough
we commit to uprooting the Legacy and
perpetuation of structural violence
deeply embedded within the Health Care
System we recognize inequities built by
past and present traumas rooted in white
supremacy colonialism the gender binary
ableism and all forms of Oppression
well you're right this acknowledgment is
not enough your apology is not complete
I will not believe that the repentance
is sincere until Dr Robert Englander
demonstrates it through self-immolation
I mean literal self-immolation like
setting himself on fire rather than
simply immolating his credibility as a
medical professional and his dignity as
a man I mean that much he has done but I
got to see I got to see the the full
thing you got to go all the way
so as we heard there it begins with the
classic land acknowledgment where
members of modern Western Civilization
apologize for being members of modern
Western Civilization granted all people
everywhere on Earth are living on land
that was once occupied and owned by
other people all inhabited regions of
the globe without exception have been
fought over and bled over and four
um no other culture though apologizes
for this fact just as Native Americans
never apologize for their own history of
conquest and bloodshed this is a
confrontation that they are never
required to have with their own past
only modern westerners are stupid enough
for this kind of thing but the greater
concern is that is that this doctor and
these medical students are in creepy
unison
declaring the gender binary oppressive
now it's theoretically possible that
somebody could be a competent Medical
Professional even while suffering from a
terminal case of performative white
guilt and that's all the land
acknowledgment stuff signifies
but it is impossible that somebody could
be a competent medical professional or
even a semi-competent one while
harboring the delusion that biology is
some sort of oppressive patriarchal
construct and conspiracy
all of their medical work must must
happen
within the context of biological
realities if they don't understand those
realities or have pledged to pretend
they don't understand them then they
can't be trusted I mean I wouldn't even
take Tylenol if these lunatics
recommended it
because they are fatally compromised
does it make sense that the same company
who controls half of online retail also
passively eavesdrops on your private
conversations at home or that a single
company controls 90 of internet searches
runs your email service it gets to track
everything you do on your smartphone
well big Tech is more powerful than most
countries are and they profit by
exploiting your personal data it's time
to put a layer of protection between
your online activity and big Tech and
that's why I use expressvpn think about
how much of your life is on the internet
sadly every site you visit video you
watch message you sent gets tracked and
data mined but when you run expressvpn
on your device the software hide your IP
address something big Tech can use to
personally identify you so expressvpn
makes your activity harder to trace and
harder to sell to advertisers gives you
more privacy and control over your
information expressvpn also encrypts 100
of your internet data keep you safe from
hackers and eavesdroppers on your
network
and expressvpn does all of this without
slowing your connection that's why it's
rated the number one VPN service by tech
radar The Verge and countless others so
stop handing over your personal data to
the big Tech Monopoly who Minds your
activity and sells your information
protect yourself with the VPN I trust
and use to keep me safe online visit
expressvpn.com Matt walshow to get three
extra months free expressvpn.com Matt
walshow expressvpn.com Matt Walsh show
and we're not done yet let's continue
as we enter this profession with
opportunity for growth we commit to
promoting a culture of anti-racism
listening and amplifying voices for
positive change we pledge to honor all
indigenous ways of healing that have
been historically marginalized by
Western medicine
I'm sorry what honor all indigenous ways
of healing all of them all are you sure
all
I mean most indigenous ways of healing
are based in paganism and animism you
know the belief that all things
including rocks and rivers and plants
and all that have souls and are in a
sense Supernatural this is the belief
system that these ideas are rooted in
primitive people it may have had some
useful medical insights about plants and
medicinal plans and all that but they
were ignorance of most of the scientific
realities that make modern medicine
possible so when you say all
are we including for example the
Primitive practice of trepanation which
is boring holes in a person's skull to
treat spiritual or physical illnesses
that's something that indigenous people
in this part of the world did especially
in South America
um so are we honoring that what about
bloodletting or topical ointments made
out of animal droppings and dead lizards
what about ritualistic and medicinal
cannibalism
is Minnesota medical school going to
start teaching those strategies too
in indigenous cultures most medical
issues are treated by Shaman you know
witch doctors who would get high on
hallucinogens and then dance around
shaking a magical stick or whatever
is that the sort of treatment plan I can
now expect from doctors who earn degrees
from medical from Minnesota medical
school if I go to the doctor complaining
of a of a of a back ache is he going to
say okay hang on a second and like dose
himself with some LSD and start dancing
around the room
chanting
perhaps so
because we wouldn't want to marginalize
those medical practices
continuing on
knowing that health is intimately
connected to our environment we commit
to Healing our planet and communities
we vow to embrace our role as community
members and strive to embody cultural
humility
we promise to continue restoring trust
in the medical system and fulfilling our
responsibilities as Educators and
Advocates we commit to collaborating
with social political and additional
systems to Advance Health Equity
cultural humility he says you know the
other thing that's annoying about all
this is that is that as always like they
they never are consistent in the
principle
um so so cultural humility in and of
itself I would I would agree with so and
there's not a lot of cultural humility
these days
which is why we we spend so much time
um you know tearing down statues and
monuments and everything and talking
about the sins of our ancestors and our
forefathers
um elevating ourselves above them
you know engaging in this kind of
chronological snobbery as uh as I
believe C.S Lewis put it
so so we're doing that
it's like people like that were that
lived before us were a bunch of barbaric
scumbags simply because they lived
before so we're better because we live
now but then at the exact same time
we're also told that well we don't want
to marginalize indigenous healing
methods
so on one hand there is no cultural
humility and then on the other hand
there's also at the exact same time this
like degrading the basing of yourself
where you're elevating these primitive
Concepts above you but all this is
racially based of course that's that's
that's how we explain the the patterns
anyway
this is a relief because uh they they
did also say there in that last clip
that they're restoring trust in the
medical system they're restoring Trust
by making me think that I'm probably
better off simply dying of any serious
disease I contract rather than
Consulting with one of these lunatics
that's how they restore Trust
but as always you know though this
footage is deeply horrifying though it
may chill you to the Bone to see what
modern medicine has become it is good
that you see it I would rather that they
utter these incantations in full public
view on camera than do it in secret
it allows us to see where we stand and
also helps us to understand that we are
dealing not with an ideology or a
political system
this is not merely you know doctors who
are partisan or have political biases
those kinds of doctors have always
existed of course
that's what we're talking about we're
talking about a religion it is a
religion unlike any other in the history
of the world because this religion is
centered around the fundamental
rejection of Truth
many religions before this have been
untrue
many religions have had false ideas
about the world but even the false and
untrue ones have strived for truth they
claim to be true they saw themselves as
an access point for truth as maybe the
only access point for truth
but this modern Western liberal religion
simply rejects truth as a category
now this is not ignorance
indigenous cultures with their often
counterproductive medical practices were
ignorance
through no fault of their own
all ancient people were ignorant they
didn't know very much about how the
physical world functions or why these
things had not been explained to them
yet many cases had not been discovered
yet
but the religion of leftism stands in
the light of Truth it stands on the
shoulders of people who have revealed
many important truths to them
and then it chooses falsehood it chooses
ignorance
as an act of will it chooses untruth
there have been false religions
this on the other hand is falsehood as
religion
and these cultists these religious
Fanatics are in positions of power and
prestige in our culture they run our
schools and our government and now they
run the medical field
which is something to keep in mind the
next time you have to go to the doctor
and that'll do it for this segment of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]